hi there so the paper we're looking at
today can take the code on the Left
which is written in Python and can
output the code on the right which is
written in C++ now the point here is
that the code on the right does the same
thing as the code on the left so it is
implementing the same function the
surprising thing here is that this model
that takes the Python as an input has
never been explicitly trained to output
C++ so this is an unsupervised
translation model and that's the the
cool thing about this paper is that by
having no target at having no supervised
signal at translating source code
languages into one another it can
perform pretty well at the task
nonetheless so we're going to look at
this paper it's called unsupervised
translation of programming languages by
Mary Ann la sha Baptiste Hosea Loic
Shanna Shaw and Guillaume lumple at
Facebook AI research as always if you
like content like this consider sharing
it out and leaving a like and also
leaving a comment if you have something
to say about it
they say a trans compiler also known as
a source to source translator is a
system that converts source code from a
high-level programming language such as
C++ or Python to another they say
trans compilers are primarily used for
interoperability and two-port code bases
written in an obsolete or deprecated
language such as cobol or python 2 - a
modern one so for python 2 you might
know this tool that's called 2 to 3 so 2
to 3 is a tool that ships with the
Python 3 standard library I believe that
allows you to take Python 2 code and
produce Python 3 code and that is to
kind of push people to convert their old
code bases of Python to two-putt to the
modern Python 3 now 2 to 3 is hand
written program it has specific rules
built-in that the programmers know if we
modify Python to like this Python 3 gets
at for example the print statement in
Python 2 requires no brackets so we make
a rule that whenever there's a print
statement with no brackets will add the
brackets such that it's Python 3
compliant most of this code will
transfer transform the source code first
into an abstract syntax tree modify that
apply specific rules to that and then
output the language from the abstract
syntax tree now the problem here is
many-fold first of all there there can
only be so much translation as there are
rules so every one of these rules has to
be coded as a modification to the
abstract syntax tree and every one of
these rules is handcrafted and therefore
needs sort of human ingenuity humans
need to go and write these rules of how
to transform one language into another
and oftentimes this doesn't even though
it it you can write these rules
oftentimes whatever comes out is sort of
a bit of a cryptic source code because
you can have to make sure that your
rules cover all the possible things and
the source code that comes out is
oftentimes very cryptic and a bit hard
to understand because it's been sort of
expanded and formalized to make sure
that it still does the same thing as the
original source code now for Python 2 to
Python 3 this is still easy right these
languages are extremely similar because
it's not that big of a step to python 3
except if you use very low-level
language language constructs or language
features which have been obsoleted with
python 3 on the other hand if there's
something like COBOL so a lot of this
old banking code or insurance code or
government agency called whatnot is
written in these really old programming
languages and they've been kept alive by
these old-school programmers that are
slowly but surely all retiring now
and there are just not many new
programmers around that can support
these languages and the languages
themselves aren't really updated that
much anymore so you would like to
transform cobalt into something like I
don't want to call Java modern
programming language but it is used in
modern times I'd rather not call it
modern per se Java itself is a beast
that's been sort of supported since
forever but in any case you would like
to transform something like COBOL to
something like Java that where you have
a lot of programmers that can develop
and further develop your code this is
much harder COBOL and Java are much more
away from each other than our Python 2
and Python 3 so what you would like to
do is you would like to have a tool that
is like 2:00 to 3:00 but humans because
now if you want a tool like this you
need someone that's really proficient in
COBOL and Java in order to write a tool
like this and you need lots of them and
they need to invest lots of time what
you would rather like to do is you would
like to learn a system that translates
from one language into another such that
the meaning is conserved and this of
course is exactly the domain of natural
language machine translation except its
source code so we all know that we've
all realized in the last years that
things like Google Translate have become
extremely good at translating so they
say right here although neural models
significantly outperform their
rule-based counterparts in the context
of natural language translation which is
Google Translate is all learned right
now they say their applications to
trance compilation have been limited due
to the scarcity of parallel data in this
domain so what's the problem with just
going and saying oh we you know we can
build really good neural machine
translation models let's just apply them
to source code the problem is if you
build a neural machine translation model
say something that transforms English to
German so you have the word hello and
you output hallo
you can do it not with just one word but
with the entire sentences and so on
these models they usually or in the
classical sense what they need are
parallel corpora which means that you
have this you have documents that are
written in many languages and you can
guarantee that they mean the same thing
so this is a supervised signal one
example of this is let's say press
releases of the United Nations
so the United Nations will make some
press release and they will then have
professional translators translate that
press release into all of the different
or into many different languages and so
you can pretty much guarantee that these
mean the same thing so these pairs of
documents or triplets or whatnot they
are supervised training data for a
machine translation model that
translates from one language into the
other and the neural machine translation
models rely heavily on these parallel
corpora for source code you just don't
have that as much you don't have big
code bases in in great numbers where the
exact same thing is implemented in one
language and in the other language
there's just not that much data
available it is the case that sometimes
sorry that sometimes let's say in the
case of torch it started as Lua and then
it went to PI torch and the developers
had to translate the code from torch to
Python but in the same in the same step
they've also made improvements they sort
of re-engineered and reinvented the
framework and made it better and so you
can't really say these are the same
things and likewise there's not a lot of
code available where the same thing is
implemented in two languages so we just
don't have these parallel corpora for
for the source code translation so
rather what this paper does is this
paper goes into unsupervised machine
translation now what does unsupervised
machine translation mean unsupervised
machine translation you imagine I
of just a big database of documents and
these documents I I know they're all
they're all in English okay and I have
this other big database and I know that
they are all in German I just know their
documents are in German but they don't
correspond to each other they're just
German documents and over here they're
just English documents they don't I
don't say that these two here are
somehow the same no I just have a bunch
of German a bunch of English they don't
even have to correspond they're just
text and now what I want to do is I want
to learn a shared embedding space I sort
of want to learn a shared space of
embeddings for these two languages such
that similar things are mapped to the
similar place so if these two documents
just happen to talk about the same thing
I want them to be mapped to similar
spaces in this shared embedding space so
I'm gonna have one model a single model
where I input the text and it goes into
this shared embedding space okay now
this is unusual because usually in
machine translation if you translate
from here from English to German then
you'll have your dedicated model that
takes as English as an input and German
as an output and that would be a
different model than one that takes even
German as an input in English as an
output or French as an input in German
as an output in this case we have this
process right here and this process
right here is the same model and then
the the decoder that translates this of
course now we have the encode or
embedding and then the decoder that
actually translates to a language is
also going to be the same model so it's
the same model that translates to
English then it translates to German so
first of all how do we make the same
model let's say let's say we have the
perfect encoder right this is e the
encoder the same encoder for all
languages let's say we have the perfect
encoder and it can map the if whenever a
sentence means the same thing in
different languages we can completely
map it to
the same point in embedding space
irrespective of the language it comes
from now how do we tell the decoder
which is also the same model like how
does it know what to do this is a little
trick where you basically you take this
embedding so you take the input you put
it into your model I don't even know how
you go this and then your output is
going to be autoregressive right so you
decode one token at a time so you decode
this token and then you feed it back
into the model and then you decode this
token you feed that back into the model
and so on this is an auto regressive
language model and the trick here is
that the first the very first token is a
special token that describes the
language you want to output so here you
say I want German and then you let the
model decode its
its thing and by conditioning on this
token right here it knows it should now
produce German you will simply during
training you will simply put the token
here and if it produces something other
than German that's a loss right so it
will learn to produce German after you
produce this tag alright so what we need
is an encoder and the decoder such that
in the encoder we can put in any
language text and it will map to the
same space the things that mean the same
things and we need a decoder that you
know can produce any language given this
first thing now the decoder should be
fairly easy right if we have a shared
vocabulary between the languages and we
we always put this token we can the
decoder is not a problem you can just
learn the decoder in a straightforward
way but the encoder is going to be a
problem so how does the encoder map the
different languages to the same space
such that the same things are ending up
in the same place it seems it seems a
bit counterintuitive right because it
doesn't know which things correspond to
which things now the first thing you
need is a shared vocabulary here since
we are in a shared space
right here the what you need is a shared
vocabulary so you tokenize all of the
text with a shared vocabulary and this
vocabulary is going to consist of sort
of word pieces now if you don't know
what where pieces are in a word piece
tokenization what you would you already
would do is you would split words into
so called word pieces so for example
hello right here might be split into two
word pieces the first word piece might
be hey and the second word piece might
be LLO okay there is usually like some
kind of indicator here that this is the
end of a word and so on but we'll
simplify and Hollow
right here would be a H a for the first
token and then ll o for the second token
and these kind of word peace and codings
since the smallest units are going to be
the characters themselves they ensure
that you always have everything is in
vocabulary you have no out of vocabulary
tokens but here you can already see that
if we tokenize the languages like this
and then we use the same encoder so the
same encoder will pop them into this
shared space that means that to the
model this and this looks like the same
thing it is the same thing right it's
the same input token in different
languages now as you can see this comes
from the same word that low at the end
in English and the low at the end in
German it comes from the same word so
you know it's fair to assume that since
it's the same input it's going to be
mapped into a same embedding space right
here or since these things are usually
context dependent we can say in a
similar embedding space alright a closed
embedding space but certainly the the
initial vectors are the same that is
already half the task right so by by
tokenizing in this way we have already
mapped part of our languages even though
there are just a different languages we
have mapped the same
word to the same space and this relies
on the fact that in this case for
example English and German and for
example French they have have
significant overlap in their words as
such so the word hello in the word hallo
they are almost the same word as letters
as word pieces and these these shared
embedding techniques abuse sort of the
fact that these languages are close
they'll say ah there will be some word
pieces that are going to be the same in
these languages and naturally because
they're the same they'll be they'll end
up in the same place in embedding space
and because because that now you have D
so what these embedding techniques do is
they simply figure out these statistical
relations between the world pieces so if
two things appear together often in the
same context they'll be mapped into the
same space as well so it would realize
there is a lot of times where ha and hey
appear in front of this low thing so I
should probably map the ha and the hey
to the same location in embedding space
so do the same relation to the low so
they would end up at the same place so
now you see even though these word
pieces are different like they they get
different IDs they'll be mapped to the
same place in embedding space because
their relation to the law is the same
and the law themselves are being mapped
to the same place because they are
actually the same so you can see that
this this partial overlap between word
pieces in the different languages
combined with the shared embedding
pre-training results in these token
across languages results in an alignment
of the embeddings so naturally the
things that mean the same things are
going to be in the same places in
embedding space either because they are
the same or because their statistical
relation to the things that are the same
is the same it is it is sort of like
these ha and the hey are
like synonyms in this shared language so
if you jumble all the jingling German
text together the model thinks ha and
hey are synonyms and therefore Maps it
to the same space this happens exactly
the same in if you only have one
language to true synonyms so true this
would exactly be the same thing in this
case all right so now we have different
languages we have a single encoder where
we can input any of those languages
mapping it to the shared space the
decoder can be trained by simply giving
it this indicator token right here to
decode the appropriate language so now
the question is how exactly do we train
this such that such that this happens
now there's one caveat in programming
languages of course we still have to
check whether that's the same or not and
we know that in programming language is
a lot of programming languages for
example the word if is the same right so
if you tokenize Java or Python or C++
the word if is the same and likewise
there is a lot of overlap between the
different programming languages and that
exactly is this correspondence to here
these models use the parts that are
overlapping either tokens themselves or
this can also be grammatical construct
and so on
they can also be overlapping and
therefore a map to the same space so if
a a construct is used in the same way
and this can be in higher layers this
can induce the same effect and they will
use that to map D and the sorry they'll
use that the result will be that they
divvy similar things in the same in
these languages will be mapped to the
similar spaces in embedding space now
this makes this example a bit weaker
because that means this method would
work exceptionally well for something
like Python 2 to Python 3 because they
of course have like a lot of overlap of
syntax and keywords and constructs
whereas something like COBOL to Java
it's more let's say doubt about that
they will they will work so well in this
paper here they've chosen
plus plus Python and Java which do have
significant overlap but especially
something like Python to Java of course
there is a lot of a difference or Python
to C++ as well Python is not typed and
so you can see a bit of the difficulty
is already in the paper here but you
have to be aware that this works less
and less the less this shared overlap is
given all right so how do you train
these models and remember we don't have
parallel corpora we are simply reliant
on having databases from having big
repositories of Python code C++ code and
Java code and they don't correspond to
each other so the first thing you do and
as I understand it you can do these
things in parallel but there are three
different objectives that achieve three
different things in these models the
first objective is the cross lingual
masked language pre-training now the
models here are going to be transformer
models with encoders and decoders and
that's comes from the attention is all
you need papers and various other papers
like this I've done videos on those if
you want to see that this masked
language model pre-training however is
from the birth paper so Burt if you
don't know that is I've also done a
video on that this simply trains the
encoder so this is to train the encoder
what you would do is you would input
code so usually in mask language model
if you train the encoder you input code
with tokens like hello there you would
then so this is your input you would
then mask some of the tokens for example
here the low and maybe the entire word
there we would scrap that you would put
it through your encoder which is this
transformer model like Burt and then
Burt is supposed to reconstruct hello
there okay Burt is supposed to
reconstruct these two tokens like it
doesn't see them
and you ask it what did I cross out and
it needs to reconstruct that so you
terrain the model to reconstruct these
masked tokens and the research on Bert
and other things has shown that if you
train with this objective the encoder
sort of learns about the structure of
code it learns about it learns which
tokens and which constructs often appear
together and therefore it learned
something about the structure of the
input and that means it can create
whatever is up here is a good and
meaningful embedding for these things
that tells you something about the
statistical coexistence of tokens and of
course since we're doing this with all
the languages so the Python goes in here
C++ goes in here without telling the
model what it is you just throw it in
there right
Java goes in there by tokenizing it and
as you see an example right here so if
this right here is C++ but in Python
this would also be if and since it needs
to learn a single encoder for all of
these languages and since the tokens
overlap partially it is going to result
in exactly what we want namely a shared
embedding space where even though the
input comes from different languages it
is mapped similar things are mapped to
similar places in the embedding space
all right so the mask language model
pre-training very quickly as you take a
piece of code like here on the left you
mask out some of the tokens here you can
see them in this mask and you simply ask
the model the encoder to reconstruct
those things okay so this is just for
the encoder as far as I understand it
the encoder doesn't it doesn't see the
thing back here it simply sees this and
you tell it please reconstruct please
tell me which words are which tokens I I
clipped out here and it's supposed to
tell you okay the first one is if the
second one is int and the third one is
the eye now if you consider what the
encode
has to do here so if you were to see
this then that pretty clearly you know
you could you could guess that that is
an if course it's not a hundred percent
but this is just pre training right so
you train it to output if here now here
you have to do a little bit more
inference maybe you've seen this for
construct a bunch of times
and you can see that this is compared
here and this is added so probably it's
an integer and then in the last thing
this is even more complicated if you
don't see that the eye is here you
somehow have to guess that what it is
it's not clear right but you can guess
that okay there's a local variable I
write here and probably it's going to be
used somewhere in this block now this
here isn't I and I don't see eye
anywhere else so probably I goes in here
which makes sense because it's an
integer and prime is an array and and it
integers index arrays and so on okay so
this is what the model does first the
second thing is we need to train the
decoder somehow how do we train the
decoder in a very similar way we make
the decoder do denoising auto-encoder
now before we just had single tokens we
just asked the encoder to reconstruct
tokens so the encoder is this box right
here this colors this box is the encoder
and the actual part that's going to
predict these words is going to be one
sort of one classification layer on top
that is going to predict for each
position the individual word now did
this is just for pre-training after the
pre-training you scrap that and you
attach it to a decoder so you attach
whatever you got out of the encoder to a
decoder and the decoder will output in
an autoregressive way one token after
another right it would output a hit
output a token right here and it feed
that token back into the decoder saying
okay here's what I've produced and now
produce the next thing it would produce
the next token and so on so it would
produce token after token the
output and now as I said I'm not exactly
sure I think they're doing all of these
things at the same time so this would
still be here but the information would
just be routed in two different ways or
maybe they do it one after another it
doesn't really matter but what matters
is in this thing here you now train the
decoder
I mean you train it jointly with the
encoder but you also involve the decoder
and you do this by doing something very
similar you corrupt a piece of code and
you get corrupted code now you can see
part of this corruption is masking like
you did before but also part of the
corruption is like here you scramble
some of the tokens right this was it was
this over here you just jumble some of
them around a bit and then you hear you
also drop a token as you can see that
the one is dropped and you simply so you
don't show this to the encoder or the
decoder you input this corrupted code
into the decode into the first the
encoder and then you ask the decoder to
give you back the original code without
showing it the original code so the the
task for the beak for the encoder
decoder for the entire model here is if
you if you see this here is corrupted
code I have corrupted it in various ways
please tell me what I originally had now
it can the masking it does the same as
before it sort of infers it this thing
here it says well probably I probably
this isn't really correct you don't even
tell it where the errors are right
before with the masking you at least
told it where the errors are now you
don't even tell it where thee where the
errors are so it needs to recognize this
here is probably correct this isn't this
I'm gonna rewrite this to that okay and
it does this one token at a time so it
first goes into da-da-da-da-da and it
needs to output the correct thing this
is I hope the difference is clear to the
masked language modeling which involved
the
involve the decoder and here also is the
first time we're in the encoder you you
prepend this java token now this as you
can see it still goes from the same
language to the same language but this
is where you train the decoder to output
a given language so here with the token
again this is the same decoder for all
the three languages the only difference
here is every time you simply provide it
with the special token at the beginning
to tell it which language it should
decode right now so this this now we
have an encoder that maps all the
languages to a shared space and we have
a decoder that conditioned on a token
like this can output a valid code in
that thing assuming this here was
corrupted code now since the encoder is
shared it should map the same kind of
corrupted code of the different
languages to the same place in the
embedding space and therefore this would
all this will already be enough to have
this model that we desire we can input
some code it doesn't actually have to be
corrupted right we can just input some
code in one language and ask the decoder
to output the other language and this
works but it doesn't work super well and
here the authors go for another idea
from the unsupervised machine
translation literature which is back
translation so back translation is a
technique where you can tune an
unsupervised machine translation model
in a way that you would tune a
supervised one but of course you don't
have supervised data so what's the plan
you will produce the data yourself using
your own model so the plan is pretty
simple it's actually contained in the
back translation name so if you have a
piece of code what you would do is you
would first use your model to translate
this to another language any of your
choice now you have no clue whether this
thing here is correct or not if no clue
and you have no way of assessing it
because you don't have ground truth what
you can do is use your model again or
actually use a a second model that you
trained in parallel
I believe in this case they could use
the same model but you can that could be
in stable and so on but in any case you
can use your system again to translate
it back to your original language your
system can do that right and here
whatever you get as an output you know
the ground truth it's whatever you
started with so now you can compare what
comes out to what you started with the
difficulty of course is if there is a
mistake you don't know which of the two
models made a mistake and you so it
could be it could be that your original
translation model made a mistake and or
it could be that your back translation
model made a mistake and you have to
find a loss function the kind of
punishes both equally or you simply keep
one sort of constant and lost free and
train the other one because at there
there's going to be a sample where you
have C++ as an input and then the
intermediate language is Python so all
of the models sort of get trained once
as an as a source to target translator
and once as a target to source
translator but I hope the the objective
is clear from the back translation so
now with the back translation you
actually you trained the models to go
from one language to another language
okay and that's the that's the final
goal even though you do it without
supervised data you now have a model
that can encode things into a shared
space that can decode into a language
and that is attuned to translating from
one language to another language so
that's that's it how this is all how
does this work
now for evaluation the question is of
course how do you evaluate models like
this for evaluation they go to this
website called geeks for geeks and this
is a an online platform with computer
science and programming articles it
gathers many coding problems and
presents solution in
several programming languages okay so
this is a website that teaches you to
code and it will have like an exercise
please do this and then it will provide
solutions in the different languages now
why is that cool and they have an
example I have an example right here why
is that cool because not only can you be
relatively sure that these different
functions that you have here do the same
thing but you can also relatively be
relatively sure that they are
implemented in the similar way right
because what this website is trying to
do is its trying to teach the people how
to how to code up an algorithm that they
think up in their head and therefore not
only is the solution correct and the
same it is implemented in in the same
way as you can see here the Constructors
this if construct is everywhere the else
if is everywhere so even though some of
the languages might have specialty
things for implementing some algorithms
these are really the same algorithmic
the same expression of algorithmic
thought in the different languages so
that is a perfect parallel data set the
problem of course is that there is not
that many so it is good enough as a test
set it is not good enough as a training
set but given that it's a test that you
can just have these as test set and then
you can input the C++ and see whether or
not the Java comes out the problem here
of course is that even though this is
very clear there are still you know sort
of many variations of how you can
implement that to even express the same
algorithmic thought so metrics from
natural language processing like blue
just aren't gonna be very good because
they look at Engram overlap and you can
write this function with very different
engrams and still be very very valid and
correct and also exact match is not
going to be really the gold standard
here so what they do is they create a
set of unit tests where for each of
these functions they
they check their input types they
randomly generate input randomly
generate a set of inputs look whatever
comes out and if the same thing comes
out in all of their test functions that
they consider this a good unit test for
that function
so whenever you your model now produces
let's say you input Python it produces a
C++ you simply put these unit tests
through the C++ function you produce and
if they produce the same output as the
Python the original Python function when
on the same inputs then you consider the
unit test to succeed and you consider
the function to be correct now this of
course this isn't this isn't it is super
duper gold standard especially with
random inputs because usually what you
want to do is test sort of corner cases
but it's better than anything else so
far I've been a long digital ket of unit
tests honestly because I think whenever
a human writes a unit test then they're
probably since they have already
implemented the function itself they're
probably going to make the same mistakes
or they're probably just going to
replicate the code and thinking of the
function in the unit test itself and
therefore it doesn't really get you
anything
I guess in large organizations you write
unit tests so that someone else doesn't
screw up your code but in this case it
would actually be cool because now as a
human you could simply write a bunch of
unit tests and then let your that your
trans compiler do the the heavy lifting
and you simply check whether or not the
output is good all right so how does
this do here you can see they have some
baselines the C++ to Java as I
understand it is a commercial system and
the Java to Python is an open source
system both are human experts that make
up these rule-based systems on how to
trans on how to translate code into
other languages now the if you do what
they have here's transcoder beam one
which means a beam size of one so if you
don't know a beam searches very shortly
beam search is like if you decode from
your language model you can either
always take the next token that has the
highest probability this will be greedy
decoding or a beam size of 1 or you can
sort of always keep the top end
hypotheses of what the of what the most
likely output is as you can keep that as
a you can keep the top 5 in memory and
always decode these 5 on sort of like
you have a mini batch of five sequences
and you always keep the top 5 in memory
so at the end of the decoding you're
going to have 5 different variants of
the same sentence or of the same decoded
output and you can then decide which one
you like best and usually what you do is
you then output the one that has the
highest probability which is not the
same as the greedy because sometimes the
next token will be will look 1 next
token will look very good in a greedy
way but you'd better take the second
most likely because the next 2 next
token is going to sort of make up for
that to make the entire sequence even
more likely so more beam size basically
means you can keep more hypotheses of
the output in memory until the end so if
you just do the greedy decoding you see
you already get fairly close to these
baselines it's very very cool very
interesting and if you up the beam size
you surpass these baselines now the way
they up the beam size here I find to be
a bit let's call it a bit cheaty because
when they say beam 5 what they mean is
they keep the 5 hypotheses and then at
the end I as I understand it if any of
the 5 hypotheses passes all the unit
tests or the most they keep it right so
basically they give themselves the
freedom to say whichever one of the 5 we
output is the best that's the one we
count and of course that's not really a
match to the
commercial order to the baseline system
because it can output one thing now it
is maybe a good practical application to
give the human that you know you input a
function you give the human five options
to choose from and it can choose and
thereby decide which one the human likes
best but it is sort of it is a wonky
what I like more is this here the beam
10 top one this is what you would
actually do say we could keep 10
hypotheses during decoding and that the
end output the top one the top likely
one and as you can see that is better
than greedy but it is worse than where
you you know give yourself the freedom
to output multiple ones of course though
they say that most of the errors that
this top one makes come from compilation
errors when the target language is Java
or C++ it suggests that the beam end top
one metric could easily be improved we
leave this to future work which this
again I find valid right so if you if
your method is I'm going to keep the top
ten hypotheses until the end and then
I'm going from the top and I simply
compile them and I output the first one
that compiles that that's not cheating
right that's a valid thing again yeah so
in that way I can I can understand what
they're saying right here okay so they
give some examples some of which I find
very interesting so the first thing here
is that oh yeah by the way I've said in
the I said that the tokenizer between
the natural languages is shared they
make a little tweak here in that they
tokenize the different languages with
their language respective tokenizer x'
which will still end up tokenizing
pretty much you know this the print
statement in C++ or in in in Java no
actually the print statement in Python
is print and enjoy its println and so on
but it will still like the other if
statements it will still
organized into the same into the same
word but it's simply not viable to to
parse Python with a C++ parser okay so
we have looked at this the results this
is one of the results they look at their
shared embedding space and this is a TCE
plots a 2d projection of this shared
embedding space and you can see that
this is actually happening so the
different sonal null and none are mapped
to similar locations println and see out
are mapped to similar locations in this
space so this is exactly what we want
this is sort of a verification that this
method of embedding the different
languages into the same space really
turns out such that whatever means the
same thing is mapped to the same place
you can see here catch and accept of two
very different tokens are mapped to the
same place simply because they're used
in the same sort of constructs across
the languages very cool one of these
examples here is quite impressive and
kind of shows the difference between
this and and rule-based translation in
this function right here you have a C++
function that takes a character pointer
to that is called STR store in as an
input now in C++ strings are at least in
old versions of C++ strings are handled
as character arrays so a string is
indistinguishable from a character array
and in this case usually what you do is
you don't input the array because that
would cause a copy you input a pointer
to the first two you input a pointer to
the array and that would define the
string okay so if you translate this
again this the type of this is simply
character array if you translate this
with this transcoder system that they've
built into Java in Java there is a type
called string right there is a
native type code string and is that true
I think oh yeah that's and then that's
handled really weirdly in the JVM I
think yes so there is a at least there
is a type called string so it would map
that it would recognize ah you mean a
string therefore I'm going to put a
string here and it uses all the string
method like string length string
character at and so on
we're in C++ this is just an array and
you just have array axises now they take
this same C++ function and only change
one thing they changed the name of the
parameter everything else is the same
but now the character array is called
error okay and they put it through the
same system and that system now outputs
a function that takes in a character
array called
R and instead of a string and it uses
you know here the property length it
uses array access instead of this car
character at method so simply by
changing the name and this is something
where I believe the the rule-based
systems can this can be an advantage of
a rule-based system because what this
here does is it simply says oh I've seen
a lot of humans in my code base that use
this use like stir as a as a variable
name and that usually means that the
construct here are like the constructs
in Java where people use strings and
I've seen other places where people use
you know names like this right here and
usually that is used in the same context
as in Java people use character arrays
so it in programming it's not only
important what the the code actually
does but a lot of programming goes via
naming of things like other programmers
will read your code and by reading stir
right here they will sort of assume that
this is a string whereas if they read
error right here they will assume you're
a pirate and you are referring to a
character array and they will treat the
code the code means some
different and these systems right here
these neural machine translation systems
can actually understand that part
because they do statistical inference on
code that humans wrote if you change
this back to say input then again it
goes back to a string and uses all the
string functions so that's fairly
impressive in my mind and it yeah
definitely an advantage over rule-based
systems of course the disadvantage of a
rule-based systems is that in rule-based
systems you can almost guarantee you can
even guarantee that the code does the
same thing here you can't they give some
examples of failed translations where so
now you get you run into this problem
where the min function in Python is
overloaded it can either give you the
minimum of a sequence or it can give you
the minimum of two things now this is
translated to Java right here and math
dot min is not overloaded in Java it
only gives you the minimum of two things
and not the minimum of an array and it
still outputs that now given enough data
probably could learn because these
things are all context dependent but
this is one of the this is one of the
failure cases of these models of course
all right so this was this paper I the
I've I've read that the code of this and
the unit tests will be output will be
put on line at sometimes they're not
right now if I if I hear about it I can
link to it or let you know about it
let me know what you think of this paper
in the comments share it out and
subscribe if you haven't yet and bye bye